Speaker 1: I'm going to play a clip for you now
of Arizona Senator Wendy Rogers saying that right
now. Yes, December 20, 22. Carrie Lake is the
governor elect of the state of Arizona. Now,
of course, Carrie Lake is not the governor
elect of the state of Arizona. I think you
probably know that. But what is fascinating
about this is I don't think Wendy Rogers
really thinks Carrie Lake is the governor elect
of Arizona. And I don't think Stephen Bannon,
who's conducting this interview, really thinks
Carrie Lake is the governor elect of Arizona.
What's fascinating about this is that it
seems to just be sort of like a power game.
Does Bannon have the power? To get Wendy Rogers
to say something that they both know, of course,
isn't true. Who wields the power in this
dynamic and it seems that it's ban and take
a look at this this is unbelievable the problem.
Speaker 5: And we need to get to the bottom of
all of this. And I just telling you, we're not
having it any more. We're done, as Carrie said.
As Kerry said, you're messing
with the wrong people.
Speaker 3: Is Kerry Lake, the governor elect of
Arizona? Yes. Is there any doubt in your mind?
Speaker 5: And and she will have an
even stronger mandate. And she told
me about a week ago, she said, you know, Wendy.
Speaker 1: By the way, if you're
watching this, Bannon's co-host
is so bored, she's just texting on her phone.
Speaker 5: When I might have assumed office had I
been elected properly. Without all this aftermath,
maybe we would have had a honeymoon period with
everybody. Maybe we would have had a transition
time of, you know, let's all get along. No.
Speaker 3: Right.
Speaker 5: You know, that that that ship
sailed. Okay. So what we're doing now is we're
going to in the Senate and in the House, we're
going to legislate. And then we will work with
her to get it all done. And people ask me, Oh,
Senator, will you take a meeting for this or that?
I go, No, not until I know who the governor is.
Speaker 3: Amen.
Speaker 1: So, of course, maybe this is
evidence of a multiverse in so far as maybe maybe
there is a parallel universe in which Kari Lake is
the governor elect of Arizona. But the universe
you and I occupy is not one in which that is the
term that applies to Carrie Lee. You know, you
can pray to Jesus. Wish upon a star. Pull out a
Ouija board, get a divining rod. Start chugging
homoeopathy. I don't know. You could do whatever
you want, Reiki. It's not going to make Carrie
Lake be the governor elect of Arizona. At another
point during this very same interview. Steve
Bannon and Wendy Rogers call on people to get
themselves arrested over Carrie Lake's election.
Speaker 3: I should not throw out. Right. This
was intentionally done to suppress the
vote of Carrie Lake supporters and MAGA
voters in Maricopa County on game day, correct?
Speaker 5: Yes. And so we're talking what we what
I want to see is people arrested.
Speaker 3: Right.
Speaker 1: Very strong arrests.
Speaker 3: Ho, ho, ho, ho. Do you think
they think Colonel Rogers should be like Judge
Roy? Be right. She's a hanging judge. Right. Get
some air. But you're not throw out, right?
Speaker 1: Unbelievable. And by the way,
when someone like Bannon gets
arrested, which, by the way, happened,
he's got the money for a great legal defense.
And they're going to make it so that he goes to,
you know, the cushy prison and all this different
stuff. When the people that watch this crap
follow the advice and they go out there and they
get themselves arrested. They're the ones that
get stuck in pretrial detention. They're the ones
with the public defenders. And public defenders
can be great. They're just totally overworked. And
they don't they just don't have the time to devote
to all the cases that are handed to them and all
of these different things. They don't care about
you at that point in time. And Marjorie Taylor
GREENE will make a show out of going to visit
you at some jail and saying it's also unfair.
It's unfair. It's unfair. But your experience,
when you get arrested on their say so
is going to be very different than their
experience when they get arrested. One other
sad, funny moment is just this co-host in the
pink dress on the right of the screen. She
just is so bored with everything. She just
texts the entire show. Look at her.
Speaker 2: Unseat Ronna McDaniel
because she's failed us.
Speaker 3: Real quickly,
give us that again. You've got to get contact with
the precinct committeemen, your precinct chair,
and make sure eventually you get up to the
two committee. There's one committee man
and committeewoman for each state.
Speaker 2: Yes, there's a committee
woman in committee state.
Speaker 1: But listen,
if I was sitting there listening to Steve Bannon
drone on about this, I'd probably be texting
someone as well. But just a horrible, pathetic,
but also extraordinarily dangerous situation.
They're just straight up lying. Kerry Lake, not
the governor elect of Arizona. She's not going to
be governor of Arizona for now. Maybe she'll run
in the future, maybe she'll win in the future. But
right now, Katie Hobbs, one. Thankfully,
Katie Hobbs is going to be the governor.